Kylie Jenner's baby girl is already
breaking Instagram records this is what
happens when Will Smith is your pops and
queer eye is back with the new fab 5
happy hump day my friends I am Denny and
I'm dressed like Cruella De Vil
alright guys Kylie Jenner revealed her
newborn daughter's name was stormy and a
sweet Instagram yesterday your reactions
were mixed many fans were speculating
Kylie would name her kid Matty polska as
in butterfly because of her obsession
with them but one of you did point out
that the Kardashians always have cute
nicknames for the kids and Stormies
could be Mimi I thought that was suck
you and some of you assumed Stormies
last name was Scott after her father
Travis Scott except that's not his real
name Kylie cleared that up real quick
and later updated her baby name
announcement the full name is stormy
webster which is baby daddy travis
scott's real last name and get this that
instagram post that has become the most
like instagram photo of all time edging
out Beyonce's baby bump revealed from
last year Kylie coming for queen bee and
i don't like it but a lot of you did now
as kylie settles into life as a mom a
source tells ET the new mama won't be
hiring any nannies no Kylie will
definitely be very hands-on and will
rely on family for support not outside
help so where does stormy webster fall
on our list of the most unique
kardashian-jenner baby names head over
to ET online.com forward slash daily
denny to find out that is when we'll be
linking all the stories of more that we
cover from here on out so go check it
out guys it's really exciting
alright now one famous family Kiley
could probably call on furnaces is the
Smith family Jaden Smith is a longtime
pal of Kylie's and Jaden's dad we'll
have you heard of him he is celebrating
his son reaching 100 million streams on
Spotify with his own shot for shot spoof
of son Jaden's icon music video you got
to check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you color icon liver start a record
label miss miss just did it
nylon couple five minutes whoa we are
too hot in the business but to make a
movie independent new trucks independent
I need you to the vision iconic I mean
those house slippers were a nice touch
or my right and the spike getting
clowned Jayden gave his dad props on the
reenactment writing quote dad this is
the funniest thing I have ever seen in
my life you're the best father anyone
could ask for and listen if you're not
following Will Smith on Instagram you
need to if you're into daddy humor
courtesy of one of the most famous stars
in Hollywood well then welcome to your
new favorite feet I'm tellin ya alright
guys and finally 15 years after Queer
Eye for the straight guy revolutionized
reality TV queer eye is back this time
on Netflix and with a new fad 5 they are
still impacting culture one makeover at
a time and I got the fellas to drop some
sage advice before all of us trying to
look better eat better and be better
take a look I feel like we should do a
queer I'd crash course each of you oh
sorry Anthony what's the biggest piece
of advice for anyone who doesn't know
their way around the kitchen like where
do they start when they wanna learn how
to cook start off with a little thing I
like to call YouTube videos of Julia
Child and Jacques Pepin yes on PBS and
way back when it'll teach you the basics
of French cooking learn how to make a
French omelet learn what goes into a
stew season every single step of the way
and Julia on YouTube I mean come on all
right Bobbi advice for people trying to
upgrade their home or office like what
are they soon you know people always say
to me they're like I can't find my style
how do I find my style and my advice to
them is find that one piece that you
absolutely fall in love with
built from that you know design doesn't
have to be daunting find the one piece
that you love let me take some I'm Bobby
come in there in two minutes
that place is gonna look amazing say
your own what's your favorite piece in
your room I do like my bed frame okay
okay you know that my wheels are turning
yeah that's happening Bobby to turn it
out right Jonathan what's one hairstyle
or trend you hope dies in 2018
what are you tired of seeing oh well
that's a keep like beating a dead horse
but I like I don't like when people like
accidentally get there like their beard
line cut real right here something like
this is all uncovered it's all yeah
because it really y'all if you want to
know tell it should be where your neck
connect or like your face connects to
your neck like that's where the line
should stop it doesn't live up here and
this down here I was gonna say because
when it's up here from the side even if
you have the most fit nice face from the
side it gives you Mitch McConnell neck
when this is all dark I'll never know
what that feels like they shall go in
their style I gonna have a gorgeous
beard my man actually I can't grow it
out are you serious because my yeah you
can use topics that's something you can
put on but I also have a tip for you to
help it grow in so whatever
alright tan what's one staple every man
should have in their closet a great suit
okay I mean I don't wear suits often but
every now and then you need a great
fitting suit and you won't regret it if
you choose something classic
sophistication if you get your funeral
wedding whatever you've got something
with it that's tailored to you tailor
your um what's doing like what like if
for someone who does have us do it and
they're gonna make their first
investment what's like the most like
well-rounded colorful because what have
you looking to not got like lots of it
in one love so it depends on your skin
tone I think if you've got a certain
skin tone that works well with let's say
a great go for that don't go with some
in this it's right with any of those
people need to understand colors and
stuff
yeah well that's hard know is it great
gray navy black but choose one that and
there's also sites online where you can
actually upload a photo and it will
color match you that's true - easy right
Cromley your questions little more
specific specific sure what's one thing
you hope the next generation of queer
eye affects in terms of culture life
what do you hope people take away from
watching this for me it's really that I
hope that people stop having a fear of
exploring who they are and exploring the
rest of the world I mean one of the
things that we did really well again
like we have a conversation in episode 3
with a white southern cop where we get
to talk about black lives matter and for
me that was something that he and I
would have never talked about together
as a confident as a black man but
because of the way that the show is
built we were open to each other we're
now lifelong friends I just hope that
moment encourages other people and any
of these things that you're scared to
talk about that you're scared to explore
that you're scared to face and that
you'll go forward and reach them and
know that you can handle them those guys
are so much fun you guys going to love
the new queer eye which is now available
on Netflix so you can binge all eight
episodes get to it we have lots more
with the guys over at et online.com
forward slash daily Denney so go check
it out and thank you guys so much for
watching
we're the puppies